e da 40 anni almeno che il nostro eco
sistema mediale sta puntando di 40 anni
perché
ricordiamo tutti che il la data di
nascita di internet 69 siamo forse nella
storia di internet jenny una terza fase
della storia dei dei community network
negli anni 70 80 il web e adesso la fase
del web 2.0
siamo ormai
assolutamente
abituati all'idea della convergenza che
era un tema accademico fino a poco tempo
fa c'era l'idea che sul medesimo canale
distributivo tutti i contenuti
multimediali vengono distribuiti
c'è una larghissima ricerca che comincia
a parlare di nativi digitali
il nativo digitale a cui ho tagliato la
testa per ragioni di privacy e mio
figlio è un bimbo di tre anni che
utilizza i libri di carta della della
disney nello stesso modo in cui utilizza
l'ipad e diciamo la mescolanza nella sua
dieta mediatica quotidiana di nuovo e
vecchio è assolutamente naturale
in questo contesto le biblioteche
occupare uno spazio particolare
a partire per lo meno dall'ottocento ma
una storia più antica le biblioteche
pubbliche diventano il luogo
operativo ma anche il simbolo
dell'accesso universale
all'ecosistema dei media un ecosistema
che nell'ottocento era molto più
semplice molto più limitato di quanto
accada acqua da oggi oggi queste
biblioteche e parlo soprattutto delle
biblioteche pubbliche
rivolte a un pubblico larghissimo non
specialistico non al pubblico accademico
non al pubblico degli archivisti non al
pubblico degli storici sono ancorate al
sistema tradizionale dei media e
rischiano quindi una rapidissima
obsolescenza
le salveremo da questo sole scienza solo
aiutandole a entrare pienamente
in una nuova fase di
cultura digitale
gli stati uniti e l'europa sono due
ecosistemi digitali diversi anche se noi
possiamo distinguere in termini di scala
in realtà quello che sta accadendo negli
ultimi anni
articolo uno scenario di divisione
radicale da un lato grandi aziende che
sono
pronte a competere su scala globale per
una nuova modalità di distribuzione dei
contenuti
amazon google apple
dall'altra in europa nessuna impresa che
oggi si è in grado di competere e
neanche ci provi su una scala davvero
globale un continente di utilizzatore e
la situazione delle biblioteche riflette
esattamente questa realtà quella mappa
che vi faccio vedere che ovviamente non
possiamo leggere in dettaglio e la mappa
di quanto oggi
siano distribuiti gli ebook nelle
biblioteche americane e il totale di
quella mappa ci dice che il 67 per cento
delle biblioteche pubbliche americane a
una collezione di book da offrire ai
propri utenti
quell'altro diagrammi non diciamo
difficilmente leggibile alla distanza a
cui siete ci parla dell'impatto delle
biblioteche pubbliche americane di
un'altra cosa che ci distingue da loro
negli stati uniti nel 2009 69 cittadini
su 100 sono entrati in una public
library in italia erano
11,7 un quinto negli stati uniti la e la
partecipazione alle biblioteche
pubbliche e maggiore della base
elettorale di fatto
in che modo può avvenire il il
cambiamento delle biblioteche che cosa è
accaduto nelle biblioteche americane e
che cosa bisogna far accadere nelle
biblioteche italiane ed europee quello
che vedete è il bancone del prestito
sembra quasi il banco del check in di un
aereo poi una grande eccezionale
biblioteca pubblica quella della città
in cui siamo una biblioteca che presta
circa un milione di oggetti l'anno ma
sono oggetti fisici quello che dobbiamo
fare il processo che dobbiamo innescare
è quello di trasferire queste
transazioni in rete passare ad un
modello di digital eni cui 16 sulla base
di questa analisi che vi ho riassunto
brevissimamente nasce nel 2009
medialibraryonline che allo stesso tempo
un progetto imprenditoriale progetto
della mia impresa e un grande progetto
cooperativo che coinvolge direttamente
le biblioteche pubbliche
siamo partiti con qualche centinaia di
adesioni a distanza di due anni siamo a
2 mila biblioteche in 10 regioni ma
moltissime altre realtà stanno
aderenti che cos'è e che cosa offre
questo servizio
si riassume molto semplicemente
anzitutto accesso remoto ai contenuti
per l'utente cioè la possibilità di
accedere contenuti della biblioteca
attraverso un portale web 24 ore su 24 7
giorni alla settimana 365 giorni l'anno
è una piattaforma condivisa che consente
alle biblioteche di cooperare tra loro
ottimizzando in un modo incredibile i
costi questo sul quale non posso entrare
in dettaglio ma la sostanza della
faccenda è che una biblioteca di aosta è
una biblioteca siciliana possono
acquistare assieme dei contenuti e nella
pratica quotidiana operativa di gestione
dei fondi bibliotecari questo ha dei
comporta ea dei potenziali di risparmio
straordinario pensate giusto per darvi
un'idea che il costo nelle aree più
efficienti del paese di una transazione
di prestito bibliotecario
escluso il costo del contenuto stesso e
tra 3 e 6 euro cioè ogni volta che una
biblioteca efficiente in italia da
prestito qualcosa spende in costi
complessivi di gestione del processo tra
3 e 6 euro se data la mia impresa questi
questi quattrini possiamo regalare
questo contenuto all ahi ahi ahi lupin
la terza cosa è una grande collezione di
contenuti digitali vi do una mappa di
massima di quello che oggi c'è qui
dentro 40.000 ebook
1500 quotidiani da 80 paesi
in quaranta lingue
tanti video ma questa è una parte in cui
dobbiamo ancora migliorare tantissimo
gli audiolibri 3 milioni e mezzo di
tracce musicali significa alcune
centinaia di migliaia di album musicali
ecco questi sono tutti i contenuti che
l'utente prende a prestito
esclusivamente facendo login su una
piattaforma e
accedendo ai contenuti della sua
biblioteca ha acquisito verso secondo il
modello tradizionale della distribuzione
dei contenuti nelle biblioteche pubblico
modelli differenziati un ebook ad
esempio l'ultimo romanzo di umberto eco
viene preso a prestito e rimane nella
nel salvato dall'utente e rimane a
disposizione per 14 giorni al termine
del periodo il libro diventa di
disponibilità per un altro utente ma in
altri per altri contenuti modelli
distributivi sono completamente
differenti
eppure tutto questo non è sufficiente
questo è un progetto importante al quale
credo moltissimo è un progetto
imprenditoriale che avrà ancora una
larga diffusione
ma questo non è sufficiente questa
questa immagine questo il fregio che
vedete è sulla public library del
compare sul portone della public library
di boston ritmo
libero ho aperto per tutti
c'è un punto sul quale siamo ancora a
tempo come paese come sistema paese a
competere con con con i paesi più
avanzati con gli stati uniti con la
corea del sud con altre realtà più
avanzate della nostra del disegno di una
grande biblioteca nazionale digitale
italiana
perché qui la domanda è è possibile
conservare l'ideale ottocentesco di un
grande contenitore del totale della
cultura accessibile per tutti oppure
questa idea è inevitabilmente tramontata
obsoleta per ragioni tecnologiche e
sociali legali
si tratta di rispondersi rispondere ed
impegnarsi su questa su questa domanda
che cos'è tutto il contenuto
ecco questa è una cosa che in realtà si
disegna abbastanza semplice lento tutto
il contenuto vuol dire tutti i libri
tutto il materiale filmato tutta la
musica
potete immaginarlo come grossomodo
un'area che alle seguente articolazione
da un lato se il materiale che protetto
da copyright
pensate ai libri ci sono i libri in
commercio
i libri fuori commercio e tra i libri
fuori commercio se neanche un
sottoinsieme piccolissimo molto
complesso da gestire che è costituito
dalle cosiddette opere orfane cioè
quelle di cui sappiamo che esisterebbe
il detentore dei diritti ma non
riusciamo a trovarlo non sappiamo dove
non possiamo identificare dall'altro
lato c'è l'insieme delle di ciò che è o
protetto da copyright
eppure licenziato gratuitamente con
delle licenze particolari molti di voi
avranno sentito parlare delle licenze
creative commons di modelli simili
oppure di opere nel pubblico dominio le
opere per i quali i diritti d'autore
siano scaduti questo modello che qui
ovviamente è ipersemplificato è un
modello che si ripartisce uniformemente
attraverso tutte le tipologie
multimediali se volete costruire una
grande biblioteca nazionale bisogna che
ci mettiate tutte queste cose
eppure riuscire in un'impresa del genere
estremamente complicato
negli stati uniti google ha iniziato una
super campagna di digitalizzazione che
ha prodotto ad oggi la digitalizzazione
di circa 15 milioni di volumi e sa che
ha incontrato degli ostacoli legali
apparentemente
insormontabili negli stati uniti e in
altri paesi del mondo
stanno nascendo iniziative nuove queste
due figure che di cui ho messo la foto
in questa in questa una delle ultime mie
di queste positive sono di robert anton
che è un grande e storico e anche il
direttore della biblioteca universitaria
di harvard che sta promuovendo l'idea
digital public library merita di una
biblioteca digitale pubblica americana è
quello che io trovo straordinario e noi
dovremo cercare di riprodurre nel nostro
paese è il fatto che questa è una
biblioteca pubblica non nel senso di una
biblioteca dello stato e della pubblica
amministrazione
la parola pubblico negli stati uniti
assomiglia molto di più a quello che è
stato definito
da elena nostro che ha vinto
recentemente un nobel per l'economia
per la sua teoria dei commons dei dei
beni dei beni comuni e c'è qualcosa un
sistema di regolazione spesso di
autoregolazione che è trasversale
rispetto alla distinzione tra privato e
pubblico la costruzione di una
biblioteca digitale nazionale oggi
implica relazioni e dinamiche di
rapporto tra il pubblico e il privato
completamente nuove assolutamente
inedite
senza le quali questo compito sarà
assolutamente impossibile da realizzare
sono necessarie nuove norme nuove
licenze nei modelli contrattuali un
sistema di regole dinamico che sia in
grado di assorbire tutte le novità che
proverranno dal dal
dall'evoluzione dell'editoria digitale
e in sintesi una vera e propria nuova
economia della biblioteca oggi i
processi di digitalizzazione del
materiale librario in italia sono
davvero alluminio il lo stato italiano
non investe un euro l'unico grande
progetto è un progetto realizzato dal
ministero dei beni culturali in accordo
con google che digitalizzerà nei
prossimi anni pare un milione di volumi
della nostra biblioteca nazionale
centrale di firenze bene quello che noi
cercheremo di fare non da soli come
impresa ma cercando un larghissimo
spettro di collaborazioni e reagire a
questo stato di fatto e provare per una
volta a reagire senza chiedere l'aiuto
dello stato cioè provare a mettere
assieme una pluralità di soggetti che
ovviamente dovranno includere anche
soggetti pubblici ma non solo
per riuscire a costruire un grande
contenitore che assomigli perlomeno e
sia in grado di competere
nel servizio offerto agli utenti a
quanto si sta realizzando
negli stati uniti e in altri e in altri
paesi
il nostro progetto è partito senza fondi
nel 2009 con pochissime adesioni
che stanno aumentando rapidamente
io ho l'impressione che questo sia uno
dei modi attraverso cui un'idea così
larga così ambiziosa può essere
realizzate cioè convincere con molta
pazienza un'enorme quantità di soggetti
del fatto che questo può essere
realizzato che c'è un valore aggiunto
fortissimo nella operazione
semplicemente che il destino in in gioco
la posta in gioco è la possibilità di
riprodurre un modello di trasferimento
della nostra cultura è anche la
possibilità di rimanere dal punto di
vista delle strutture di accesso alle
conoscenze ad un ritardo ragionevole dai
paesi più avanzati
la mia impressione che non solo chi ci
governa ma in generale chi ha
responsabilità nell'ambito dei contenuti
non abbia una percezione chiara della
gravità di questo ritardo ea questo
bisogna reagire non tanto con manifesti
non con iniziative politiche ma con
azioni pragmatiche molto precisa grazie